please welcome our old pal
[Applause]
ah
I know I know hump day
right yeah Thursday okay well take it
easy well so nice to see you great to
see you my man you look you look
fantastic
yes you always do I have to ask you I'm
a little confused okay about your face
there's face paint you're worried face
painting I know what the significance is
I don't know what's happening right now
I I was at a kid's birthday party and I
didn't have time to wipe it off my face
cuz I was running late I know how you
guys like to start on time yeah yeah for
groanin show yeah
look out yeah pretty much done in show
me much done in show business a great
kid kid by the name of Justin uh-huh
eight years eight years old today
yeah and it was a it was a great time
yeah you're at Justin's uh Justin if
you're watching I love you pal yeah
now is is Justin you have kids is Justin
a friend of one of your kids no I don't
know Justin no I'm sorry you don't know
him is he is the neighborhood kid yeah I
mean sorta like a mile away okay well
why were you there well I'm driving home
and I see this house with a bunch of
party balloons and you know bouncy house
in the back and I'm like that looks like
a kid's birthday party yeah
walked in turns out I know his old is
his old lady
oh you know his meow his mom yeah I used
to hang out for what yeah so I thought
what's going on here yeah and she says
Justin's birthday yeah I'm like can I
stay next thing you know I'm getting my
face painted like a tiger yeah I think
that's a great I think that's a very
sweet story you went to a birthday party
you got your face painted let's we I
think we had a great time really fun and
I hated to leave yeah but it's great to
be here thank you and thank you
now will ya I'm just gonna move on with
the interview and we're just gonna
forget that this is happening up here
that yeah you would be foolish to do
anything else yes of course yeah
you